Missy Rachel and it was just uh it was  cathartic I guess in a sense did you say  everything you needed to say and hear  everything you needed to hear I did and  she she said everything I think that she  did what she did because she just has to  howl her heart and you so many feelings  for yeah I opened up a lot to her than I  had with anyone else so there's always  maybe a little part of me that feels a  certain way about her but ready to move  on to the next thing and as well so that  thing I did love you like I had I was  falling in love with you like that was  real tonight Rachel said that she did  love you how did it feel to hear that  did she say um I don't know it's a bag  of mixed emotions I guess I I know what  she said was real I know what I said was  real and it's just it sucks to watch it  all play back I guess it's like you're  reliving your breakup  [Music]